[Music]
nine-time Pro Bowler Pro Football Hall
of Famer here care of once again
Nutrisystem good to see yes thanks rich
game here buddy
Marino thank you how long have you been
with Nutrisystem oh you know it's been
ten years you know yeah yeah ten years
ago I did a program through a friend
lost some weight and start doing the
men's program yeah yeah we're now we're
here promoting it and got a new program
called lean thirteen no why would it be
thirteen because you can lose thirteen
pounds right also my numbers 13 now you
know we had Kurt Warner he should be on
the lean thirteen so I'm just we should
get him in the program yeah but did you
ever see the number thirteen and think
maybe we shouldn't do it well how did
you where so you know what I have told
the story many times it when my dad was
a little league coach and most dads
would actually let their son pick the
first number you know yeah he wouldn't
let me pick right so all the other kids
would take the numbers and thirteen used
to come up you know I was little when I
was like seven eight nine years old yes
and then after that I didn't high school
Mike let me make this number of mine and
I wore in high school or in college or
for the Dolphins it's so you never that
was kind of it now never worried about
it didn't you just yeah cuz Kurt said
the same thing you never thought for a
single second that thirteen would be a
problem though you know that we made it
lucky well that's true and now it now it
fits into the to the Nutrisystem program
that you got going on there sit here
please come on now
sitting here on the Rich Eisen show set
I'm sure you're asked a lot of Brady
legacy questions so let's hit Matt Ryan
how about that how about flipping the
script um yeah what do you know of Matt
Ryan cuz I know obviously the Dolphins
were in the game of thinking of drafting
and many many years ago our selves was
there and they decided not to correct
but you know what I know of him is just
outstanding competitor just what you
know got to meet him a couple times but
never really spent a lot of time with
him you know for him this is the biggest
game of his life obviously you know
playing in the Super Bowl he's probably
gonna be the MVP and he had an MVP year
I think the big thing and I say this
because you know I don't know what that
felt like is the leave on a Sunday last
game
here leave you know the world champion
you know I lost the game I played it for
him that's that's what he's gonna if he
wins that's the feeling you'll have
there's no one will ever be able to take
him away from him and that's the beauty
of it and so you know hopefully he does
that and everybody wonders on the other
side Brady Belichick in that combination
quarterback coach combination what was
your relationship with Shula like that
helped you do what you did at such an
early part of your career it was uh it
was outstanding he was always there for
me as a player and as an individual you
know on and off the field just you know
he was a true professional a guy that
you could learn from how to work you
know the work ethic you know the time he
put in and was respected no no wasn't
that it was you know he's you know
quarterback and head coach spent a lot
of time together sometimes you know more
than you actually see your wife during
the season sure cuz you're meeting so
much and and so we had a great
relationship you know the one thing I
say it's tell a lot of people when I
came in as a rookie he did something
pretty unique he wanted me to call my
own plays in practice and in preseason
games which I don't think a lot of
people thought about that back then and
it really made me study so much harder
and learn so much quicker and I was able
to you know come in and play my rookie
year and start and have a pretty good
year so you know that's just a kind of a
coaching thing a lot of people don't
know about which is just letting you be
yourself let me be myself but also
learning different situations and
learning quicker instead of a coach
telling your ear this is you know and
you just repeat the call you can go and
run the play you actually have to think
about what you want to call for each
situation then we you know repeat it to
the rest of the offense then run the
play so I think it makes you learn a lot
quicker dan Marino here on the Rich
Eisen show earlier we had Howie Long
here if I had to put you up against
Howie Long in terms of acting yeah in
terms of movies a filmography versus
filmography yeah yeah great great great
what you've got though I have a lot of
respect for her yes but I'm gonna say
I'm a better actor because of right yeah
and oh well he was oh and how about
about yeah bad boys bad boys
- arrow froze it's a broken Broken Arrow
he did a really good job of that well he
was he was he was kind of though he was
the lead admirer something he was right
was the lead okay
so I'll still take credit mm-hmm so you
would be able to how did you get
involved actually with the the Ace
Ventura
it was about a whole year process but
whatever year process like someone came
to me with the script the Super Bowl
before that we did it the next year so
in our read the script and they were
baffled we were thinking about doing
this and then it ended up I went on on
my way the next year to the Pro Bowl I
was gonna tell it Jim Carrey and Tom
Shadyac we mentioned Tom Shadyac that mm
I actually wasn't gonna do the movie cuz
I thought the script was a big you know
joke and wasn't very good mmm and then I
met Jim Carrey and all of a sudden I'm
like you know what this might be funny
might be a lot of fun oh uh I end up
doing it and and it turned out to be a
pretty cool so you do the scenes yeah
and have people come up to you ever
believing that Ray Finkle is a real
individual in dolphin's lore Dan I don't
think they believe it that he's real but
they come up to me and say you know
Finkle and Einhorn and lace is out there
in the Hall of Fame I get I get a lot of
that you still do thanks walking up to
you
yes talking about laces out alrighty
then and then what's that line about the
gum there's a line home alone I can
recite a few movies for beta man now
it's not an impressive
now Brockman can you recite any of his
bad boys two lines
oh well dan Marino is test driving a new
Cadillac in Dan in bad boys 2 and Will
Smith and Martin Lawrence they need to
use his vehicle for police services and
Dan Marino's anything you need dear yes
yeah the great job I took my Cadillac
yeah it was it was the best line of the
movie yes officer take my car yeah
a lot of facial accident a lot of
nonverbal acting that was good did you
actually wear isotoners at any point
like you're in Miami and you're
embracing isotoners and a sweater which
is a odd oh my god Miami isotoners in up
north yeah I did the commercials that's
I mean if you think about it a guy it's
pretty good marketing a guy from Miami
selling gloves
let's get you man that's like selling
toners that's right you're selling uh
sunblock up and uh up in Alaska or
something like that I like it I like it
so so okay so you got broke it you got
the bad boys too and you've got the Ace
Ventura lines that people are are you
creeped out by that sort of thing right
now
no I guys think it's funny fantastic
good to see you Dan the the Nutrisystem
lean 13 program lose up to 13 months in
your first month of dieting yeah super
Monday yes my Monday super Monday is the
biggest decision day for men on whether
they should be on a diet or not it's
Monday after the super because people
are just binge well they just yeah
through the playoffs they want to you
know have their nachos and their beer
and everything else yeah after sunday
then they go can we'll talk after the
show I got you covered whatever you need
13 it's super Wednesday for law right
now it's super Wednesday good to see you
Dan okay thanks the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience